with almost 70 years of service the
queen has traveled more widely than any
other monarch in british history with
tradition and duty has been passed on to
each generation and in the past was
always widely celebrated but in recent
years questions have been raised
repeatedly about whether the royal
family should do more to address their
colonial past
well prince charles attempted to broach
a subject during a three-day tour of
canada
as we look
to our collective future
as one people sharing one planet we must
find new ways
to come to terms with the darker
and more difficult aspects of the past
well sunday times royal editor roy
nicard joins me now along with uh kaindi
andrew professor of black studies at
birmingham city university welcome to
both of you so roya
you've been around this royal block a
long time um it seems to me that what's
been happening
is with these royal tours which used to
be not that controversial
one normally pretty celebratory they've
become now almost every single time
controversial and it all goes back to
colonialism to the british empire how
much the royal family on behalf of this
country should be apologizing for the
sins of our past you've been on a lot of
these tours are you feeling a rising
tide of controversy about that
um i have to say in all honesty no and i
think it depends where you go i mean i
was in belize with the cambridges i went
to barbados with the prince of wales for
the handover and actually he made a
really interesting speech during that
tour he talked about acknowledging that
slavery was abhorrent but he didn't
apologize william did the same in
the caribbean but he didn't apologize he
he talked about they acknowledged our
past i think it's right to do that and i
think we've got to recognize it it
sounds apologetic to me it doesn't
matter i should say the words i'm sorry
but there's a lot of regret a lot of
we've got to look back on the past a lot
of revisionism back to a previous era
history and i just wonder
where that stops because isn't it going
to affect every tool they do i don't
think so and i think it's a recognition
by members of the royal family and the
palace and the government on who's whose
behalf they're traveling on lots of
these stalls that we are in different
times we didn't have towards the best
part of two years we are in different
times black lives matter has happened
other movements have happened and i
think the royal family feel it's their
it's their role to sort of stay relevant
to acknowledge when things have gone
wrong and i thought that statement by
william after the caribbean tour was
fascinating he acknowledged that things
had gone wrong and said the whole point
of talks is to go and hear and listen
and reflect um i i don't think it's the
role of family to go around the world
apologizing
and they've stopped short of that and i
think there's a reason for that
interesting distinction let's bring in
candy andrews
i know you're not the world's biggest
fan of the monarchy in fact you might
well be one of the least biggest fans of
the monarchy um but putting that aside
kindy this issue of whether the royal
family on behalf of britain
should be going around
expressing themselves in the way that
they are about the colonial past about
the empire and so on
my question for you really is does it
really make any difference why is
everyone clamoring for the royals to do
this does it really matter if the royal
family keeps saying we've got to think
about what happened before we've got to
reflect and so on
well i think it's a bad time is what i
would say it's the 21st century and the
queen is the head of state of 15
countries including my families from
jamaica and it's frankly been ridiculous
since independence and is ridiculous now
which is why these topics are coming up
i mean i do agree with you on this one
though i mean an apology is meaningless
i mean apologies pointless this is about
reparations this is about repenting and
really there's nothing the royal family
could do in the queen in particular to
to apologize other than really resign
get rid of them got gone and give all
their money back to the people they
stole it from in the colonies i mean
look in a way it's the same debate that
people have been having in america and
britain about statues for example
of people who perhaps were controversial
public figures who had good sides and
bad sides from churchill we saw uh the
statues of churchill mandela and gandhi
boarded up at parliament square we've
just seen margaret thatcher's has been
egged within hours of being put up
you're seeing the same thing happening
in america my point about that and about
the british empire and all of these
things is that
there is good and bad in all these
things
why are we so preoccupied we ask the
question why are we so preoccupied with
looking back to times in history and
focusing almost exclusively now on the
negative
because a is not just history so if you
and b the history is so negative it
shapes the present so when you have a
tour of the royal family and bear in
mind the royal african company was the
company that enslaved more africans than
any other company in the entire world
that got rich off slavery they got rich
off colonialism the queen still wears
jewels from india when she goes around
to these places etc and they're wealthy
because of that oppression and then you
go to about jamaica and the caribbean
which is poor we're only there because
of slavery because of that oppression
that's not something happened
historically there's something we're
dealing with today which is why people
as opposed to does britain get issued
because this is not something in the
past right but does britain get any
credit for
helping to abolish international slave
trade do you give them any credit for
that the country
no when you are that when you are the
country that enslaved more people than
anybody else you don't get any credit
whatsoever for finally deciding to stop
that practice really no there's no
credit deserved and it's faster faster
for to suggest so no society there's no
society could have already for stopping
slavery right but yeah that's where i
don't agree with you i think they should
get i think every one country's people
should always get credit for
acknowledging things are wrong and
changing them otherwise how do you ever
evolve as a society
no but then so then if you're going to
acknowledge it that means you have to
repent for it that means you have to
repay that what does that mean
the only thing the royals can do on this
issue is renounce the throne dissolve
their assets and give them to the
caribbean and india and the rest of the
colonies simple that that is repentance
that is reparation right anything okay i
agree if he was pointless okay
right i mean look it's i i get why
passions run high about these these
things i get some of the points cane is
making
the royals aren't going to do this
though are they i mean this there's a
limit to i think how far this is going
to go i mean the royals will say we need
to
market and respect it and look back and
reflect and so on but they're not going
to go as far as candy's talking about i
do they're definitely not going to
renounce the throne and give up all
their assets and return them to the
caribbean and and the rest i think what
we've seen in the last three tours is is
the mood music change we've heard uh
charles and william reflecting on the
past um they've that's clearly been in
conjunction with the government in the
foreign office but i think that is
probably as far as they're gonna go
you're gonna be very busy the next
couple of weeks one question for you
before we let you go is the queen going
to make her own jubilee lots of i mean
she every time we think we're not going
to see her again up she pops looking
dazzling and radiant my prediction on
that is yes she will she will because
she's just the ultimate trooper right
she's the ultimate trooper i think we'll
see here at trooping and i think we will
see her fingers crossed fingers crossed
if she feels up to it at the epsom dome
despite your reluctance to celebrate the
monarchy will you say anything nice
about the queen on as she celebrates her
platinum jubilee
i don't even know what data is it that's
how much disinterested i have this whole
debacle
candy always good to catch up with you
thank you very much for joining me and
roya thank you very much